can we have a little freakout moment  right now two more seasons of this is uh  I know it's super exciting right two  more seasons 36 episodes over two more  seasons of this is us they can't really  digest that I wrapped my head around it  right now I think we're all we just like  keep giving each other eyeballs like  what is happening it's pretty cool we  just got the good news happy it's good  it hasn't sunk in yet I'm like and I  literally was like what what did she say  did you say it again say it again yeah  it's really exciting it's more than  exciting this is the best job I've ever  had I have so much fun on it I love all  of these people and for someone to be  able to you know let me do it for two  more years and hang around with this  fine group for two more years is is a  blessing it's truly a blessing  [Music]